newly revealed body camera video shows
what appears to be the immediate
aftermath of the police raid that killed
brianna taylor in louisville
the video obtained by vice news seems to
show a possible violation of police
policy after the shooting
cbs news has obtained other evidence
showing the one shot fired by taylor's
boyfriend
may not have hit an officer as the
kentucky general
claims adriana diaz reports that a
former detective who faces criminal
charges in this case
seems to be in this newly released video
over the weekend never before seen body
camera footage obtained and released by
vice news
appears to show former detective brett
henkerson who was involved in the raid
that killed brianna taylor
walking into the crime scene after the
incident according to vice that's him
with the flashlight asking about shell
casing
upstairs oh that's ours it looks like
but
i'd back out until they get tiu in here
cbs news has not been able to verify the
video
if hankinson was indeed at the scene
after the shooting that would be a
violation of police policy
which states officers involved in
shootings are to be isolated from all
non-essential individuals for the
remainder of the initial investigation
that was just tremendously shocking
angelo pinto is an activist with the
group until freedom
that works with taylor's family he says
the video is troubling
it looks like and i think it's clear in
some instances that a lot of
departmental policies were being
violated
but an attorney for the officer who was
shot says these body camera videos don't
show anything substantial
he says the officer still acted in legal
self-defense
this state document raises additional
questions a portion of the kentucky
state police ballistics report obtained
by cbs news
appears to not support state attorney
general daniel cameron's assertion
that taylor's boyfriend kenneth walker
definitively shot sergeant jonathan
mattingly the night taylor was killed
in part it reads the bullet that hit
mattingly was neither identified nor
eliminated as having been
fired from walker's gun walker's
attorney steve romine
says he has seen the full report there's
also evidence that kenny shot
actually hit the carpet in the apartment
walker was charged with attempted murder
of a police officer but the case was
dropped without prejudice
walker's co-counsel frederick moore says
this means the state could charge him
again
if they see fit they can't really prove
what kenny knew
when he fired the shot right which is
the element essentially for attempted
murder
it's unclear if the ballistics report or
the body camera footage were presented
to the grand jury which decided
wednesday not to charge anyone with
taylor's death
attorneys for taylor's boyfriend have
filed a motion for all the evidence
presented to them to be released
an attorney for brett hankinson who will
be arraigned today said he's never seen
a ballistics report
adding quote unlike a lot of lawyers i
do not try my cases in the press
i try them based on evidence in the
courtroom the police department's
internal review
is ongoing gail adriana has so many
questions in this case steve bro mine
when he
when he was here last week kenny
walker's attorney actually used the word
cover-up to describe this case and
that's one of the reasons why people are
still marching in the streets because
they want full transparency
to see what evidence the grand jury was
presented with
absolutely a lot of protesters are
talking about that exact
thing but prosecutors like the attorney
general say no such thing happened and
that the
officers here acted in legal
self-defense right well the questions
continue thank you very much adriana